imagine going into whack tomorrow so
here you've been made redundant with no
payoff because you've not been there
long enough but you've got a little
money in the bank enough to get sorted
you'll start the job search but then
companies just don't get back to you
this is not going to plan you go down
the pub spending your savings whilst
continuing the search but your partner's
had enough of you're not contributing
and leaves you struggle to pay the bills
before you know it you'll be hind you
lose your home and you're stuck but no
worries because you can stay with
friends till your sausage accepts that
after a month they too have had enough
of you and now you're really stuck
you're homeless does this story sound
far-fetched it really shouldn't I
despair at the state of homelessness in
this country the numbers are increasing
and just as bad the way we're treating
these people seems to be declining in
recent weeks we've seen hermus people
kicked in the face as they sleep blasted
with red spray pain while they're
sitting down and even have lit fireworks
shoved into their pockets our homeless
are not a different species they are
people just like us who have often
fallen on hard times we must come
together and say no more we need to care
for our own and this issue must stop
being a political football used to score
points I'm not immune to becoming
homeless are you
[Music]
we shall write not five years ago I had
to I had to borrow a terrible Caravan
stick it on a building site and living
it alright and get whatever I could
every day filling buckets and they're
tipping them in bins okay
and technically I was have no fixed
abode
I had nothing not a proverbial pot to do
the obvious in all right
homelessness is hideous is tragic and
anyone round this table could be to poor
decisions or to bad pieces of luck from
being in exactly the same boat okay you
crash your car because you're riding
your phone you've done something stupid
you've lost your part leave lost Utah
boom you're out okay it can happen to
anybody and I think it's for everybody
in this country that that at the back of
their mind when they're walking past
someone who's sat there was pot out
because he's down on his luck or her
luck alright I find it absolutely
abhorrent that anybody would do
something detrimental to these people
who are already on the but you know that
better sign that saddens me obviously
very deeply inside that saddens me but
it can happen to anybody Majeed and I
absolutely brakes me it breaks me you
know and I know there's no short or long
term fix of actually sorting all these
problems out but to make it worse for
someone's out there it's absolutely
disgusting
so I everything you you said in your
intro and and what you just said Phil
really touched my heart and completely
resonated with me a few years ago I
volunteered at a homeless shelter
cooking for the homeless and part of
what we would do was we would sit and
have dinner with the people that we were
cooking for and I was blown away because
homelessness is not something that I had
done much working you know in terms of
my charity work and I was blown away by
how many stories of people who had
decent jobs who had families and like
you say two or three decisions
losing your job and not getting another
job in time in that sort of six-month
buffer
ended up on the streets and these were
people that would get dressed every day
still going for interviews and still
trying to get back on their feet and
it's terrible because the problem with
our social security system particularly
where housing is concerned is we have a
safety net for people who have children
and we have a safety net for people who
we see as priorities but the people that
you're talking about there is literally
nothing figures so this is from autumn
2007 at 17 so just in England to learn
4751 people sleeping rough and I just
think we live in a country where by like
I often think if you if you're an alien
and you come from outer space and you
come into this country and you see
people driving they're fast cars and
then mansion houses and then you turn
the corner and then you've got somebody
on the street how would I even try and
explain himself and the concern that
I've got because you're saying like as a
sight we're walking on by I actually
think it's getting worse I think that
people are walking by but they're there
I've got some figures it's a 15 percent
increase from the year before and 73
percent increase over the last three
years so the problem is getting worse
people's the thing that's getting me is
having sensitized yeah he sensed house
but also do rocketry so when I've just
listed three examples there I've got so
many more examples there's an example of
someone returning back to his sleeping
bag to find that someone's you urinate
you just go to a quote from crisis so
you have a look at what they've said the
sad fact is they've said that every
night thousands of people across the
country are sleeping rough in doorways
bus shelters all on public transport
many are subjected to appalling violence
and abuse something our frontline staff
witnessed the effects of everyday we
can't carry on like this when we know
that the homeless that homelessness is
not inevitable it is tragic that it does
seem to be I remember even just so you
go back five six years not seeing as
many people as I now see out on the
streets and and you know you can you can
go to certain places where you know they
try and gather for some
and then I often wonder that certain
measures are then put in place by local
councils like spikes to make sure so
that people can't lie down e and you
just think these aren't you know pigeons
that you don't want to you know so this
is what the Minister for housing and
homelessness have a wheeler MP had to
say it is simply unacceptable that
anyone has to sleep on the streets and
I'm determined to put a stop to it we
have set out bold plans backed by a
hundred million pounds to have rough
sleeping by 2022 and end it by 2027 as
part of a 1.2 billion pound investment
in tackling all forms of homelessness we
know that we have more to do and we will
I think it all started in the financial
crash and then you know nobody stopped
there's no affordable housing rents of
spiraled out of control landlords can
kick people out of their houses within a
month's notice
and nobody's gripped it and actually for
it's quite a small amount of money
yeah people could be put back on there